welcome to deconstructing chatbots I am
Priyanka Vergara and in this episode we
will learn how to integrate a dialogue
flow agent with Bitcoin if you've not
checked out our previous episode on
fulfillment I highly encourage you to
watch that before you continue here
because we are going to use our same
appointment scheduler chat pod that
creates appointments in Google Calendar
today let's enhance it to send
appointment information to bigquery to
gain some insights from dissapointment
data so let's jump into our dialogue
flow console and see how to set up the
fulfillment to send data to bigquery
open appointment scheduler agent in the
dialogue flow console and navigate to
fulfilment in order to integrate with
bigquery the first thing we need to make
sure is open packaged our JSON and add
the bigquery dependency now before we
make edits to our indexed rjs let's
first set up our bigquery data set in
GCP console under resources on the Left
pane click on the project ID once
selected you will see create data set on
the right click on create data set and
name it once the data set is created
click on it from the Left panel you will
see create table on the right now
provide table name and create the table
click on the table and edit the schema a
date time and type as the three fields
for the appointment time and the
appointment type take note of your
project ID data set ID table ID and the
schema fields we will need all those in
our fulfilment indexed rjs code is
linked in the description below first
create a bigquery constant we will
scroll through the google calendar setup
code for creating calendar invite please
watch the previous episode to learn how
to integrate Google Calendar with
dialogue flow fulfillment in our make
appointment function
after the calendar event is set we are
calling our bake query function ad to
bigquery which will add the same
appointment information into the
bigquery data set we just created let's
check out the function add to the query
we are passing in the agent and the
appointment type then we are modifying
the date and time into a readable format
uncomment the code and add the project
ID dataset ID and table ID to make that
bigquery connection we are using our
schema fields date time and appointment
type to create a row entry into a query
at this point we have all the
information we need we call our big
query object to add the row in we
finally catch if there are any errors
once you have made the required edits to
the index dot J's
copy and paste it into the fulfillment
cloud function within dialogue flow and
click deploy now we are ready to test in
the simulator on the write query your
dialogue flow agent with something like
set an appointment at 8:00 p.m. on tenth
and respond to the follow-up questions
to provide appointment type information
I'm using license as an example here you
will see an appointment set up response
in the simulator and it will show up on
the calendar as well now navigate to
bigquery and execute select star from
the table query to verify that a row was
added for your recent test with the
appointment type from within bigquery we
can explore this data to find
interesting insights click on the
explore int data studio button
which takes us to data studio here say
we want to know how many appointments
are for license
versus registration versus others it is
as easy as dragging the pie chart and
editing the values we want to see I'm
also interested in knowing how many
total appointments are set up
another bar graph that tells me
appointment breakdown per day with that
is pretty amazing in less than a minute
let's summarize what we learned today
we enhanced our appointment scheduler
chatbot by creating an integration with
bigquery we created a data set and a
table in bigquery and connected it to
our fulfilment then we tested our agent
to confirm that the data is being sent
to bigquery finally we were able to
explore the data in data studio through
one-click explorer feature within
bigquery comment below to let us know
how you are trying this integration in
your specific use case I will see you in
the next episode of deconstructing
chatbots until then please like and
subscribe to our channel for more such
content
[Music]